I was so happy when the
- (laughs)
- story of Robert Kraft
going to the Orchids of Asia
massage parlor in Florida
came out that we were
as far away from the podcast as possible.
I was thinking, okay,
by the time we get back
this will have died down.
It's kind of like old news and weird
to be talking about it now,
because of every story
that we've talked about
on this podcast that could
potentially get me in trouble
with the company that pays
my employment, this is it,
this is the one that I'm
the most worried about.
This is the story that is
most likely to get me fired.
- (exhales)
- So I don't want to deal with it.
Everyone knows what happened.
- You know what?
I didn't want to deal with
the suicide of my friend.
But I did it.
- [Woman] (laughs)
- Can't keep playing the suicide card.
- So I want you to break
this story down for me.
I'm a little familiar, you know.
I don't work for the NFL Network,
so I'm not privy to the
details that you are.
Gregg, do your job right now,
and break this story down
for me, piece by piece.
- All right.
Robert Kraft, Patriots owner, was charged
in a Florida prostitution investigation
Palm Beach State Attorney released--
Anthony's dancing.
We're not using this as our social video.
We're not using it as anything.
He was charged for two charges,
of soliciting prostitution
- That means he went twice,
they caught him twice on camera.
- Right. He was Male 13,
and I believe he ended up
being Male 8 as well.
Two times within 24 hours,
and one of those times
was actually the morning--
- Two within 24 hours?
- [Gregg] Yeah.
- He went back?
- It was like nighttime, and then, yeah
it was like 5 o'clock.
This is 5 p.m., and then he
came back the next morning
before taking a flight
that morning to Kansas City
for the AFC Championship game, on the way
to the Patriots sixth Super Bowl!
How about that.
- I feel like the Super
Bowl is null and void
I think they might take it away.
- Oh, please. Like, this is one of the--
There's a lot of things about this story
but one of the most annoying things is
non-Patriots fans being like "Oooooooh!"
Like, "How are you feeling now?"
It's like, I don't give a shit.
- [Anthony] Nah. Nah.
- [Gregg] You know.
It's like--
- That's what's so great about this story,
it doesn't take away
anything from the team.
It's not like--
- I don't root for the--
I don't get into sports
to root for the owner.
- I met him once.
I was hiking with Jeff Ross,
and he and his supermodel
girlfriend asked me
to take a picture of them
in front of a street sign
that I guess was the name
of one of their friends
and Jeff Ross said, "Go Patriots."
And I just stared at him.
Because, you know what, I
could see it in his face,
you're the kind of guy
who goes to sex slaves.
- [Woman] (laughs)
- Well, he didn't you know, so
that's the bigger story is
everyone is focused on Kraft
and it's like, it's a bigger
operation of that, you know
underage sex workers and all that
and that's all serious
- [Anthony] Listen
- I don't know how old they are.
I don't know if they wanted to be there
or didn't want to be there,
that's besides the point.
The funny part of this
to me is that it's a...
it's a massage shack.
That's how I'mna say it so
my mom can be okay with it.
It's a massage shack, you can get a
half-hour massage
and happy ending.
It's a half an hour away from his house.
- [Woman] (laughs)
- He can get people to come to him.
I don't know if you guys are familiar
with how the sex service industry works,
but you don't have to take
- We know you are.
You don't have to take a road trip.
They'll come to you, you know what I mean?
And, I don't know if he was,
like, in love with one of them,
but it's hilarious to me
that this guy went there,
to do that,
twice in 24 hours?
Amazing.
- [Woman] (laughs)
- It's like, maybe he'd never
gotten a hand job before.
That's the only way I can
think he would go back twice.
Like, he was like, "Oh my God,
- [Woman] (laughs)
"I've been doing it wrong
"the whole time."
"I gotta get back to this massage parlor
"half an hour away."
I wish I could hear him
telling his driver where to go.
You know what I mean?
That would be funny.
"Uh, Manuel...
"take 19, down to uh...
that strip mall.
"And then wait for me for 30 minutes."
- Way to be racist with the driver
- Manuel, I think it's
a common Florida name
- [Gregg] (laughs)
- I don't think I'm being racist
- If you read, so this
is all public information
they released the
probable cause affidavit.
One of the things that stuck out to me was
that he hugged the woman...
each time.
So, that would, to me that was
the strangest thing about it.
- In the beginning or the end?
- Both.
He hugged hello.
He hugged hello, there are some details.
It has it all written out, one of them
included one woman,
included oral sex being performed
and the other one,
actually, included two women
in the room, it was a repeat woman
and yeah, it talked about
massaging the genitals.
- And, uh
- [Gregg] The two women
- That is phenomenal.
Listen, and you guys don't have
the money that I have to be
throwing at sex workers.
- And it was $100.
- Yeah, a hundred bucks?
He can do better.
Like when Jerry Jones,
remember those pictures
of Jerry Jones with his, like, pant leg?
Those girls were expensive,
that he was with.
He wasn't going to...
He wasn't going
to get a half and half
in 30 minutes or less.
I think that all the other
owners are making fun of him
so hard right now.
Every single NFL owner has
had sex with a sex worker.
I would guarantee it.
- Stop
- Oh, I would guarantee it.
That level of money--
- How about Gayle Benson?
- that travel?
- Gayle Benson's the worst of all of 'em.
- [Woman] (laughs)
- Okay? Gayle Benson, I don't even want
to get into Gayle Benson.
Gayle Benson's gettin' happy endings.
Gayle Benson's gettin' happy beginnings.
Gayle Benson, for lunch,
gets a little happiness.
Alright, everyone knows that.
Everyone.
- Erica and Emma are
beaming with the thought
that my career is ending
- [Woman] (laughs)
with every word.
- Jerry Jones is laughing right now.
- What about the Packers?
They have that whole thing
where there is no owner,
but you can buy a stock certificate,
so there's like, hundreds, there's tens
of thousands of owners.
- Mmm hmmm. They have, like an orgy, like
in the second Matrix movie,
where they go to Lambeau,
and they all just start
writhing on each other
- The worst movie and the
worst movie scene ever
- It's the worst
- [Gregg] It's the worst movie ever
- It's the most, like,
why did you do this to us?
We loved you and you ruined us
with this scene in this movie.
But it's like that, in Lambeau.
And then, at the end of it, almost like
in a Santa Claus type way they have money
in their pockets.
- [Woman] (laughs)
- They don't know how it got there.
It's 40 fish, and bread.
It's that kind of thing, it's biblical.
- If we were ranking the fan bases
that you'd least want to see
in a stadium-filled orgy,
I feel like the Packers
would be dead last.
I mean,
they would be right there.
- [Woman] (laughs)
- I don't know, I mean I don't know.
- [Woman] I agree.
- Listen, I don't know if you guys
have ever been to Philadelphia.
But, it is a...
it's a dark mirror of what
normal people look like.
So I would think, I would
put the Eagles in there.
You know, but I'm sure
the people who own stock
in the Packers are ugly, ugly people.
- They have it, like,
framed in their family room
and everything.
Very happy.
- [Anthony] Of course.
- Of course.
But whoever has the most of those
has the most paid-for sex.
- [Gregg] (laughs)
- It's just what you
do when you own a team.
They don't have to be slaves.
Sex slavery, I'm against it.
You know what I mean, you
want to be a sex worker
that's what you want
to do, it's a fine job.
I hope for more protection
for them, you see
the way they handle it in Europe.
Here it's starting to
get a little bit better.
I'm not against sex workers--
- [Woman] How do they handle it in Europe?
- It's like, they're government tested.
You know what I mean, if you go
through the red light
district in Amsterdam,
which I'm sure you will,
- [Woman] (laughs)
- they have to get tested, they
have to have a certificate.
It's like, you get in an elevator
- It's like in Vegas!
Isn't it similar in Vegas?
- I don't know.
- [Gregg] I don't know.
- [Gregg] I've never been there, but--
But maybe, possibly? I don't know.
- [Woman] (laughs)
- I know they're trying
to do better for it,
but there's sex workers who
are like, "This is my job,
"this is what I do,
I'm not ashamed of it."
Okay.
There's people who've
been abducted, and lied to
and kept in a room.
That's way worse.
- [Woman] Taken?
- A little Taken. A little Taken action.
Although, why would you
steal an American girl,
when you know Liam
Neeson's coming for you,
when you can just take,
some of these girls
from these, like, Russian towns where they
just want a better life,
and they get lied to,
and they're told they're
going to be a singer,
and then all of a sudden
they're addicted to heroin.
If you haven't seen the
movie Eastern Promises,
go see it.
It'll tell you everything you
need to know
about Robert Kraft.
♪ (Driving industrial theme music) ♪